fin du voyage du premier ministre en
nouvelle calédonie michel rocard tient
jusqu'au bout son langage équilibre
entre les deux communautés
partisans et adversaires de
l'indépendance respecte également leur
promesse de réconciliation pologne des
tanks grévistes et gouvernement d'accord
pour négocier sans conditions le général
jaruzelski pourrait également
sanctionner plusieurs de ses ministres
la guigne pour la championne cycliste
française jeannie longo à quinze jours
des jeux olympiques de séoul elle tombe
se blesse il pourrait bien déclarer
forfait mais tout espoir n'est pas perdu
voilà monsieur bonsoir 5 millions c'est
le nombre approximatif de français qui
pendant ce week-end emprunteront leur
voiture pour principalement rentré de
vacances
les responsables de la sécurité routière
attendent avec inquiétude la
comptabilité des accidents lundi matin
dans la mesure où pour le mois de
juillet déjà on a battu
malheureusement je dirais tous les
records en franchissant la barre des
1000 accidents en france 1087 exactement
une augmentation de près de 15% par
rapport à juillet de l'année dernière
cette semaine le premier ministre a
lancé un cri d'alarmé annoncé des
mesures certaines ont déjà été prises
comme est la présence des préfets sur le
bord de la route sanctionnant sur le
champ les chauffards initiative
spectaculaire mais dont l'efficacité
voire la légalité est contestée par
certains
thierry calmont l'oeil du radar l'oeil
du gendarme vitesse plus de 90 km h sur
route où plus de 130 sur autoroute
contravention est reconnue mais pendant
nos vacances l'oeil du préfet est aussi
sur la route et regarde le conducteur en
infraction
ce haut fonctionnaire peut sur le champ
suspendre votre permis de conduire
entre le 12 et le 15 août une centaine
de préfet de sous préfet ne s'en sont
pas privés celui de seine maritime par
exemple a retiré plus de 200 permis en
quatre jours près de 2500 automobilistes
ainsi suspendus en toute légalité
le préfet étienne la loi en l'espèce les
articles 18 et 18 1 du code de la route
le pouvoir de suspendre provisoirement
le permis de conduire d'un conducteur
qui est commis
des infractions limitativement énumérées
au code de la route
il s'agit d'une mesure provisoire qui
est subordonnée à la décision judiciaire
précisant défini c'est à dire que c'est
le préfet qui donne le permis et c'est
lui qu'il retire à sa discrétion
c'est l'application d'un principe très
ancien qui a été dégagée dans l'art et
la bonne un arrêt du conseil d'état en
date du 8 août 1919 leuze permis de
conduire est un certificat administratif
de capacité à la conduite des véhicules
qui est délivrée par le préfet
aucun application du parallélisme des
formes peut être suspendu par la même
autorité qui la délivre une mesure dite
de sûreté comprenez applicable
immédiatement ceci est confirmé par la
loi du 11 juillet 75 à la cour de
justice européenne de luxembourg on
confirme pas de contradiction avec le
droit communautaire
la plupart des associations d'usagers ne
conteste d'ailleurs pas la légalité de
cette mesure
vous allez jugée brutale et inefficace
d'abord améliorer la formation du jeune
conducteur aujourd'hui on est capable
d'avoir de passer son permis de conduire
en dix jours comment voulez vous qu'on
est l'expérience pour rouler en toute
sécurité
deuxièmement on consacrerait une somme
importante dans des campagnes de
sensibilisation et d'incitation parmi
votre proposition proche de celle du
gouvernement un contrôle technique
efficace et fréquent des véhicules
d'occasion ainsi que le permis à points
usagers et pouvoirs publics semblent
d'accord pour éviter l'hécatombe sur les
routes
quant à l'efficacité du couple radars
plus préfet il faudra attendre les
statistiques
oui comme si les embouteillages naturel
entre guillemets ne suffisait pas sur
les autoroutes du sud de la france
aujourd'hui le comité de défense des
commerçants et artisans avaient organisé
une opération escargot ralentissant la
circulation notablement
ils entendaient ainsi obtenir des
pouvoirs publics une table ronde sur les
problèmes du petit commerce à l'horizon
des années 92 80 nouvelle calédonie fin
du voyage du premier ministre michel
rocard jusqu'au bout les signataires de
l'accord de paris messieurs la flore
d'un côté tjibaou de l'autre ont
respecté leur engagement devant les
différentes communautés et michel rocard
aura lui aussi
tenu le même langage au caldoches et
kanaks rappelant aux uns et aux autres
leurs responsabilités réussir la
réconciliation
l'impartialité également en attendant le
choix final indépendance ou non dans dix
ans rachid arhab georges en scène monde
accroît la balade tout érable pour
michel rocard et pierre joxe dans le
nord de la nouvelle calédonie rencontre
avec un cultivateur
anti-indépendantistes un caldoches au
franc parler
depuis trois mois il s'est passé des
choses quand même elles suffisent port
de l'espoir à moi car c'est le monde est
d'accord matignon c'est govou qui
premier mini va devoir krichbaum jeu
lafleur serrait la main ça m'a fait
chaud au coeur
ouais mais c'était à paris nouvelle
rencontre ensuite avec jean marie
tjibaou le chef vieux punk qui ait eu un
geste envers le premier ministre en
faisant hissé le drapeau français sur la
mairie de yang n un drapeau qui ne
flottait plus ici depuis des mois un
signe de bonne volonté supplémentaires
depuis les accords de matignon
ça peut changer à nouméa dans les
magasins dans les rues
quelque chose a changé grâce à vous
monsieur le premier ministre
kasha monsieur blanc et la mission de
dialogue
grâce à votre gouvernement grâce à je
dirais la démarche volontariste des
députés lafleur
hommage à jacques lafleur qui lui aussi
a fait un geste en se rendant à une
réunion qui ressemblait fort à un
meeting à des pendentifs une bonne
volonté générale
je dirais qu'on sorte michel rocard vous
avez tous sentis il se passe aujourd'hui
quelque chose d'important
mettons nous mettez vous au travail pour
construire la nouvelle calédonie de vos
espoirs
c'est le seul moyen de n'être pas des
assistés cette forme là de
l'indépendance miséreuse dont jean-marie
qui va où là ce temps disait qu'il ne
voulait pas on n'achète pas la dignité
d'un peuple avec des subventions
dernier signe de la réconciliation
engagé ici les drapeaux quelle que soit
leur couleur ne sont plus grandi comme
des armes mais simplement arborait comme
des emblèmes un immense progrès par la
nouvelle calédonie de la politique
française se résument en un sondage est
une interview selon l'ifop pour le
compte du journal
li manche la cote de popularité de
monsieur mitterrand monte de 2 points
51% de satisfaits au mois d'août contre
49 au mois de juillet 31 % de mécontents
en août contre 32% en juillet pour le
premier ministre monsieur michel rocard
41% de satisfaits au mois d'août même
pourcentage qu'en juillet et 22 % de
mécontents en août contre 23 pour cent
en juillet l'interview c'est au journal
du dimanche également le ministre
centriste du commerce extérieur et maire
de metz jean marie roche dit que
l'ouverture n'est pas finie et ne fait
que commencer au contraire on le verra
dit il
dès les élections cantonales et ensuite
un peu plus fort encore aux municipales
du printemps prochain il ajoute ce qui
n'engage que lui au demeurant raymond
barre pourrait bien être le second
premier ministre de la législature de
françois mitterrand à l'étranger
premiers témoignages sur un massacre au
burundi une ancienne colonie belge
d'afrique centrale aux affrontements
entre les deux ethnies qui composent
deux pays a succédé une répression de
l'armée affirment les réfugiés qui sont
arrivés dans l'état voisin du rhône
à une nation elle-même pauvre et qu'il
n'a pas les moyens en tout cas de
subvenir aux besoins de ces milliers
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants fini
pour la longue colonne des rescapés ils
sont 44 milles à être arrivé au rwanda
et les écoles ont été transformés en
centres de secours et de premiers soins
pour ceux qui ont réussi à échapper au
massacre
ici la question n'est plus qui a
commencé mais pourquoi l'armée du
burundi dominé par les tutsi at-elle
confondues maintien de l'ordre et fin de
sang tous les témoignages sont
accablants
la famille à l'intérieur c'est un
anglais de 15 et les officiels de
l'extérieur et sept blessés voici les
premières images de l'attenté de la
survie filmé par la télévision belge
les deux ethnies hutus et tutsis sont
ici réconcilier dans le même dénouement
plus de maison plus de récolte et la
peur au ventre alors que le gouvernement
du rwanda a tenu à souligner la
précarité de la situation de ces
réfugiés qui devront rentrer chez eux
rapidement ce petit pays n'a ni les
ressources alimentaires ni les
installations sanitaires pour faire face
à cet afflux de misère venue du burundi
le riz commence à manquer comme l'eau et
le bois
même si l'aide internationale qui a
commencé à arriver mais à l'abri pour
quelques nuits
la commission d' enquête américaine
commandé par le ministère de la défense
sur la sphère de l'airbus des lignes
civile iranienne a battu par un navire
de la flotte de l'us navy
c'était en juin dernier avait blanchi
l'équipage de l'ue ss-27 ça c'était la
semaine dernière aujourd'hui bien ce
même ministère de la défense américain
washington a fourni à la presse un
document d' amateur filmée par un marin
sur le croiseur vincennes dans la salle
des commandes du bâtiment au moment même
où le tir était ordonnée regarder berne
arménienne nous sommes donc le 3 juillet
dernier à bord de l' us vincennes
tout l'équipage est sur le pied de
guerre trois vedettes rapides iranienne
viennent d'attaquer un navire commercial
étrangers pendant quelques minutes le
navire américain va se tenir à distance
mais soudain l'écho radar indique les
trois vedettes iraniennes se regroupent
et semble se diriger vers lui s
vincennes un premier ordre est donné
tirer au canon contre les iraniens afin
de les dissuader de s'approcher du
navire c'est à ce moment là qu apparaît
sur l'écran radar un avion non identifié
selon nbc ce sont 12 avertissement que
l'équipage américain va lancer à
l'appareil
aucune réponse ne leur parvient on
décide alors de tirer un missile
nous l'avons vu nous l'avons touché dans
la salle de commandement les cris de
joie éclatent
la cible a bien été atteinte l'équipage
de l'uss vinson apprendra quelques
heures plus tard qu'il s'agissait d'un
airbus civil iranien et que le missile
vient de provoquer la mort de 289
personnes
oui à genève ou irakiens et iraniens
discute aujourd'hui d'un éventuel traité
de paix la négociation ne reprendra que
demain le secrétaire général des nations
unies monsieur déclare a voulu que que
ce samedi soit une journée de réflexion
pour les négociateurs des deux pays en
effet il apparaît que la délégation
iranienne est mécontente des positions
irakienne notamment sur un point précis
celui du statut du châtel à rabin hester
qui qui mène au golfe arabo persique et
qui est le seul accès de l'irak à la mer
les iraniens voudrait que ses os soit
reconnue internationale les irakiens et
c'est l'une des origines du conflit
d'ailleurs ne sont pas d'accord nos
envoyés spéciaux à genève ont été les
seuls pour l'europe à recueillir
aujourd'hui l'interview la première
interview du chef de la délégation
iranienne
le ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur waida coup interrogé par
ici à khost et patrick golomer déserté
aujourd'hui le palais des nations unies
à genève irakiens et iraniens se sont
donnés un jour de réflexion avant de
reprendre les négociations
comme prévu le point de blocage concerne
les 200 km de frontière que forme le
fleuve chatt el arab artère vitale pour
les irakiens
ce n'est pas la priorité pour les
iraniens nous sentons que les irakiens
et c'est de mettre en avant de nouvelles
conditions préalables au plan de paix
prévue par les nations unies les
irakiens avaient du reste procédé de la
même manière à new york lors de la
première série d'entretiens il parle
maintenant du déblaiement du fleuve
chatt al arab
nous nous disons que nous sommes
d'accord mais que le déblaiement du
fleuve est consigné dans le 6e
paragraphe du troisième protocole du
traité d'alger de 1975 qui parle très
clairement des opérations de déblayage
solo dont nous appliquerons ce protocole
mais pas maintenant
aujourd'hui nous devons parler du
retrait des trous sur les frontières
internationalement reconnues
ensuite de l' échange des prisonniers de
guerre
et finalement en temps voulu et nous
parlerons du nettoyage du châtel arab
health à l'intérieur de l'article du
troisième protocole de l'accord d'alger
voilà un signe de détente aujourd'hui
signe au pluriel joie les a acquittés
les chantiers navals de gdansk où il
était retranché avec des grévistes
depuis la semaine dernière
départ après l annonce par le
gouvernement de négociations sans
conditions avec les grévistes mais pour
l'instant ces discussions il faut le
dire n'ont pas commencé en revanche on
peut très rapidement s'attendre à des
changements à l'intérieur même du
gouvernement polonais la position du
ministre intérieur jamais été remise en
cause à perfectionner votre question
plus miné de l'intérieur et l'opposition
en marge de cette situation en pologne
mais reflète tout de même de la vie dans
ce pays ce soir sur antenne 2 dans
l'émission les enfants du rock un numéro
spécial consacré à la musique rock
polonaise à varsovie le rock ressemble
bien sûr à celui joué ailleurs dans le
monde mais il est aussi le reflet de la
tension et d'une certaine forme de
désespoir qui existe dans ce pays
pour lui
et la france a tenu à leur ex les fronts
louis pour 4 ouest ont notamment établi
l'ordre
faux
à voir
ce soir sur antenne 2 événements
aujourd'hui entre les deux irlande le
gouvernement du sud a vendu au nord un
membre de l'ira robert russell que vous
voyez sur ces images recherchées par la
police de belfast et qui se trouvait en
prison à dublin les changes a eu lieu
sur la frontière entre le nord et le sud
cette extradition s'est effectuée en
vertu d'un accord passé en 1985 entre
londres et dublin qui prévoyait une
certaine forme de coopération entre les
deux pays contre les militants de l'ira
même si l air l'irlande du sud est
plutôt de coeur avec les catholiques du
nord aujourd'hui à washington le
candidat démocrate à la présidence
michael dukakis et son rival malheureux
jesse jackson commémorer le 25e
anniversaire du plus célèbre discours de
l'histoire récente des états unis il y à
25 en effet jour pour jour le pasteur
noir martin luther king rêvait tant
public de l'avenir des communautés
noires et blanches qui constituent les
états unis aujourd'hui le problème n'est
toujours pas entièrement résolu disons
qu'il est il est moins visible mais
toujours réelle mais à l'époque
souvenez-vous john kennedy était au
pouvoir et sa volonté de faire respecter
les droits civiques des noirs dans le
sud des états unis avait plongé le pays
au bord de la guerre civile valérie soir
pour homme et pour les gens de couleur
un duel en noir et blanc l'amérique des
années 60 ne se mélangent pas au risque
pour les plus téméraires de connaître la
honte c'est dans ce contexte ans le 28
août 1963 que deux cent mille personnes
massées devant le lincoln memorial à
washington
écoute le pasteur martin luther king
je fais le rêve que mes quatre petits
enfants pourront un jour vivre dans un
pays où ils ne seront pas jugés sur la
couleur de leur peau mais sur la nature
de leur caractère la foule subjuguée
silencieuse puis je fais le rêve qu'un
jour sur les rouges colline de géorgie
les fils des anciens esclaves et les
fils des anciens propriétaires
d'esclaves pourront s'asseoir ensemble à
la table de la fraternité c'est
l'ovation
un an plus tard il recevra le prix nobel
de la paix une balle arrêtera net en
1968 son rêve d'une amérique sans
barrière de race aujourd'hui aux états
unis où célèbre l'anniversaire d'un
discours qui insuffla l'espoir à tout un
peuple celui d'être enfin libre
enfance informations générales à
marseille l'arrestation de cinq des neuf
auteurs présumés des neuf auteurs
présumés pardonnez pas de liaison du
hold up avec prise d'otages d'une agence
de la caisse d'epargne au mois de
février dernier les arrestations ont eu
lieu à marseille et en espagne à
l'époque souvenez vous hais les
malfaiteurs avaient quelque peu
ridiculisé la police dans l'épreuve
contre la montre par équipes sur route
elle est à l'hôpital
et pas sûr de pouvoir se rendre aux jeux
olympiques de séoul où pourtant elle
représente une sérieuse chance de
médaille pour la france il n'y a pas
tellement
francis maraude 50 km contre la montre
par équipes et les françaises en tête de
l'épreuve au 40e kilomètre avec 50
secondes d'avancé
pour jeannie longo cécile odin et
catherine marsal c'est la revanche
malgré le forfait de virginie lafargue
et son remplacement par annie robert les
françaises à 10 km du but sont
pratiquement médaille d'or elles
viennent de rattraper les allemandes
pour longo c'est la deuxième médaille
d'or qui se profile dans ces
championnats du monde
et puis dans un virage c'est la chute de
longo nous ne la verrons pas car la rtb
ne couvre pas l'événement à cet instant
premier diagnostic fracture de la crête
externe de la hanche gauche et déchirure
d'un muscle fessier alors séoul
est ce déjà fini pour jeannie longo qui
espérait tant un titre olympique le seul
qui manque à son palmarès alors en
direct avec nous et pour prendre tout de
suite de ces nouvelles de sa chambre
d'hôpital en belgique jeannie longo
jalil vous m'entendez bien alors génie
on pensait que votre blessure était
assez grave en début d'après midi vous
vous semblez peut-être un petit peu plus
optimistes ce soir non de poser les
choses le dr porte m'a quand même
or a des côtés ce que m'a dit que d'ici
quelques jours normalement je pourrai
reprendre
qu'avez-vous exactement ya le problème
c'est surtout une énorme douleur dans
ses salons mais ce que c'était que
j'essaie de faire un mouvement avec ma
jambe et se fera sans problème alors
qu'allez vous faire
cette semaine vous allez essayer de
remonter sur un vélo et vous allez
prendre une décision faut d'abord
quelques jours de repos complet
et puis proclamation commentera il ya
combien de chance ce soir si on devait
les évaluer en pourcentage que vous
puissiez vous rendre à séoul 55 ans
jeannie longo s'est pas vraiment une
question c'est une évidence vraiment pas
de chance et je crois que la médaille
olympique c'est la seule qui vous
manquent dans votre carrière
alors à los angeles vous avez cassé
votre guidon je crois à 800 mètres de
l'arrivée et là une blessure à 15 jours
de près on fait des problèmes intérieurs
mais ils ont par ailleurs
si vous laissez ces camps tout fait
d'avoir raté ses pédales pour les clips
pour les filles de ma compagne à qui
méritaient pas les croire et c'est toute
attente en mai jeudi à l'entraînement
qu'on avait fait avec mon mari
l'équipe était bien fondée mais c'est
quoi enfin on était bien on pensait pas
trop pouvoir obtenir une médaille c'est
que l'équipe avait été modifié à la
dernière minute donc était peut être pas
en avant c'est raté merci en tout cas
jali nous avoir répondu de votre chambre
et vous souhaite bonne chance nous
souhaitons tous bonne chance on espère
que vous allez vous rétablirez sans
familiarité excessive
on vous embrasse bien fort et bon
courage merci formule 1 automobile à
demain un grand prix de belgique l'enjeu
est bien une option sur une option
sérieuse même sur le titre de champion
du monde pour alain prost ou à ayrton
senna qui sont actuellement
vous savez à égalité ils partiront
d'ailleurs tous les deux en tête comme
d'habitude je dirais le brésilien devant
le français finalement cette saison aura
été tellement dominés par les mclaren
honda que l'on peut se demander ce que
les autres écuries qui regardent ce duel
presque en spectateur bien pensé bien et
le chameau cartonne senna ou alain prost
c'est la bagarre bien sûr de cette année
88 pour l'instant c'est ayrton senna qui
a une tête d'avancé ce championnat du
monde avec deux victoires en plus
en tout cas toute la presse parle
évidemment de ce duel qui monopolisent
complètement l'actualité de la formule 1
est bien sûr cela jette un petit peu
d'ombré sur les autres équipes et sur
les autres pilotes
et principalement sur les autres pilotes
français philippe streiff de l'écurie aj
est sous le cherche même plus à savoir
qui de profs ou de senna est devant au
moment des essais pendant les trois
jours des seuils est vrai compte
t'occupes de ce qui se passe devant à la
limite je vous dirais même que à l'issue
d'une journée d'essai jeu souvent je ne
sais même pas qui a le meilleur temps
j'aimerais que le palmarès d'alain prost
résume pour l'instant toute la formule 1
française toute la france se regroupent
autour d'alain prost et ça permet un
petit peu de bien parler de la formule 1
alors je répète attendant notre retour
au duel pas de soleil de l'oas pas
beaucoup d'eau est à la fois qui s'offre
à lui
il ne participe même pas à la séance
d'essai la piste détrempée impossible
d'améliorer le temps d'hier
ayrton senna grand spécialiste des
pistes lui et bien sûr lui au volant et
a aucune raison de sortir leur temps
j'ai fait des essais ce matin sous la
pluie et la family pleuvait encore plus
je fais quelle impression va s'éprendre
1h avoir tourné les autres ces plaisirs
soit on s'en va la tête de tous les gens
en face de bouc qui est rien et qui vous
regardent d'un air malicieux d'hôtes
danner un petit peu dit peu méchant ça
c'est très sympathique
demain 11e tata face sénat pour la
neuvième fois de la saison sera en pole
position poste est juste à ses côtés on
termine avec le festival de cinéma de
venise qui ouvre demain avec la
projection d'un film qui date de 1926
film réalisé par un metteur en scène
russe alexandre volkov son titre
casanova son décor venir
cette présentation est un véritable
exploit dans la mesure où le film dans
sa version complète avait disparu il a
fallu leur constituée presque
entièrement un travail à la fois de
fourmies et de dentellières nicole cornu
longo à quelques encablures des
gondoliers et des touristes c'est tout
les doux dans un décor cher à visconti
que sera projeté casanova tourné à
venise justement mais en 1926 par volkov
ici comme ailleurs la fête et les femmes
sont les plaisirs favoris de casanova
joué par le grand acteur ivan mosjoukine
un film coloré en partie à l'époque au
pochoir mais qu'il a fallu reconstituer
avec des négatifs abîmé venue de prague
rome londres ou paris à la cinémathèque
fallait beaucoup de patience il fallait
faire des essais coupez recoller revoir
jusqu'à je puisse avoir une continuité
j'espère que c'est la vraie continuité
de volkov avec casanova c'était que des
bribes
j'ai même pris des chutes pour
reconstituer le film aucun moyen de
repères là puisque tout avait disparu
un travail de re création donc comme
pour le compositeur georges delerue qui
sans partition originale a dû imaginer
ce qu'aurait souhaité le réalisateur
pour illustrer ses aventures et ses
images
j'ai joué le jeu vraiment avec des
synchronisme et beaucoup de beaucoup de
fantaisie c'est amusant à faire c'est
très dur c'est à dire que a dirigé en
direct c'est vraiment il ya un exploit
un peu sportif si vous voulez parce que
c'est 2h15 d'attention
il faut vraiment être synchrone tout le
temps mais je j'ai vraiment joué le jeu
de la comédie j'ai pu justement ray
seuil est d'être le plus fidèle possible
à cette somme qui ont cité des images en
écrivant une musique j'espère on aimera
60 ans plus tard c'est en tout cas une
rencontre éblouissante de talent
termine comme traditionnellement le
samedi soir avec d'abord les résultats
du tiercé du quartier qui se courait
aujourd'hui pour gagner il fallait jouer
le 9 le 14/07 et pour le quarté vous
rajouter las et si vous empochez cette
somme bravo quant au pronostic de demain
toujours tiercé à deauville voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès 9,4 15 7 14
5 11 le numéro 8 est non partant voilà
tout de suite après ce journal les
prévisions météo avec josé blanc
lapierre et puis le dernier journal en
fin de programme avec philippe lefait
quant à nous si vous voulez bien on se
retrouve demain à 13h bonsoir excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne
hu